- Yeah, but I'm
sure like people,
I'm not doing this for people
that are already in the game.
I'm doing this for everybody
who hasn't started yet. Got it?
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("A Dollar A Day"
by Rakeem Miles)
Listen to the same
exact song for five hours.
(clicks tongue)
That right there.
Real quick you'll
see the image here
I just posted in
my Instagram story.
By the way, if you're not
following my Instagram stories,
huge mistake. I feel
like that's become an
incredibly important place.
Though, I've upped
my Snapchat game, too.
Been upping it like everybody
asking me like Instagram story,
Snapchat stories?
Both.
Like what happens if tomorrow
Snapchat drops some sort of
feature, it changes everything?
Everybody's gonna
be scrambling back.
Stay consistent.
Stay consistent as long, if
something gets big enough stay
consistent until
it's dead or explodes.
Twitter. Gonna
definitely do a retweet club.
Gonna come up with something.
Getting a little momentum
believe it or not on Twitter.
Listening a lot there, engaging.
Comes so natural.
Though I'm getting more serious
about my Instagram comments too.
Oh anyway, that exchange DRock.
So that photo,
that exchange.
That's what sparked it.
People like, it's the way,
you know I sent
it to you, right?
How to get people started.
How does one get started?
Let me see. What'd she say?
So basically, I'm gonna make a
video that's gonna go bonkers
I think of how to
start. How to start.
I think it's going to be
predicated on getting people to
state their manifesto,
whether that's your mission or
where you're at
right now. Your truth.
Manifesto you know the
kind of, the what, right?
Frame it up, you
know to like the what.
The how is there's
only certain few ways to
communicate in the world.
Written word, video or audio.
So that's the next thing.
So you got got a talk about
your truth or your mission.
Then you've gotta figure out
how you're gonna
create that communication.
Only three true pillars.
That's it. Written word,
audio or video.
That's it guys.
That's how you communicate.
And then, number three
where, the distribution.
How you gonna get it out?
How to start. Got it?
Manifesto or your
state of the union, your truth.
Maybe in a little clip
from me sitting in the actually
definitely a clip from me
sitting on the airplane in
London where I look like Darth,
like a Star Wars character.
Same shit I hear
from everybody who wins.
You know, I think the
fear of losing trumps the
excitement of victory
for so many people.
(laughs) Very good.
("A Dollar A Day"
by Rakeem Miles)
Put me in a position to
be a real partner or player.
I'm very empathetic to
the real life business
you're dealing with.
I'm aware. That's
why I reached out to you.
I didn't know what that was.
They emailed us and we pushed a
meeting that we were supposed to
have because of that and
I figured I'd come to you and
like really have
this convo, you know?
I'm telling you right now, you
need to take a step back and
give a real thought.
You don't really know me but
I think your intuition on me is
right I think I can be a big
plus here instead of a minus.
I'm very interested in risk,
especially if I
believe in somebody.
I mean this is a
long game. Right?
I can lose the entire year and
win with you in four years.
I'm very open,
I on the other hand,
am sitting with a lot of extra
people so I have an asset that
I can deploy so I don't know
what that means but you should
definitely keep that
in the back of your mind.
Again, I think we're talking
about skill sets and politics so
they don't blend all the time
so I'm very empathetic but
there might be a way.
I mean, look, they're might be a
way for the scope to be
directly with you,
right? And small.
I think a lot of things are
going well in my direction and
I can see this really being a
huge win for me if I played this
right and the downside is,
my only downside
is that you know
that I'm even smarter and better
than you think and you feel like
I did the right thing.
That's not a very big downside.
How much in fee
are we getting? All-in?
Right, we can use it.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)
Getting started is
always the hardest thing.
It's just so difficult
for so many people, crippled.
You know just the starting point
seems to be the thing that most
people can't figure out.
Through these different
exchanges I'm starting to figure
out a cadence here.
I haven't made a detailed post,
kind of a step one,
step two, step three.
It's really not my style.
It's a little bit
more from the hip,
from the heart but
I think I got something.
I think I really have
this kind of step one,
step two, step three.
Starts with the manifesto.
You have to
produce a piece of content.
And remember this is not for
people who have already started.
This is singularly for people
who are sitting and have not
started putting their name or
their business into the world.
They're crippled
by how do I start,
how do I get into
the social media game,
how I put out my stuff?
Very simply,
step one, the manifesto.
Either why you want to start
putting out content or
what you're gonna start doing
or where're you going or
what you about.
The why or the what.
What are you about?
Who are you about to become?
Or what you want to happen.
For me, legacy of being an
entrepreneur or giving advice or
you're starting this
journey to talk about
your barbershop, right?
Manny, how old's
this barbershop now?
Four months?
- Five months.
Manny's first video should have
been five months ago like here,
we're starting.
We want to change the game.
This is why we did it.
This is why we left our shop.
This is what we think we can do.
This is the beginning.
Either what you're
trying to accomplish or
why you're trying to do this.
Number two, is where.
Where do you put
out the content? Right?
There's only really three core
ways in the current internet to
really communicate to the world.
The written word, so you
blog, you post on LinkedIn,
you guest blog on
different sites, you write.
By the way, you can
even do this on Instagram.
You can take a photo
and write seven paragraphs.
I actually think
it's a good strategy.
Same with Facebook.
Take a stinking photo
and then write 13 sentences,
19 sentences.
Or video, what
I'm doing right now.
YouTube, Facebook Video,
Instagram one minute versions.
Video is the other
way we communicate and
number three, audio.
The boom of podcasts.
So many people.
Am I talking,
it's screwing you up?
I love it.
Podcast boom, right?
There are people that
kind of popped whether
Jordan from Art of Charm
or Pat Flynn or Lewis Howes,
it was audio that
became their kind of
saving grace and their platform.
So, first you got
to figure out what or
why you want to talk about it.
And then number two, you got to
figure out where you're gonna
deploy your first
piece of manifesto content.
This rant, this mission
statement, this manifesto.
And then finally, where
is this stuff gonna show up?
Distribution.
Such a big part of the strategy.
Cool, you figured out
what you're gonna talk about.
I want to save the world
from babysitting mistakes.
I'm gonna be the
babysitting expert.
Cool, you figured
out how to say it.
You recording it to your voice
memo on your phone and
you just kept going. Right?
You figured it out.
You ended up being
good in a radio voice.
But now where does it go?
So this get very detailed.
Obviously, if it's written
word you look at the Mediums,
the LinkedIn, the WordPresses,
you start a blog, right?
Or you go down your Facebook
or you do it on Instagram.
If it's video
you've got YouTube,
you've got Facebook,
you've got Instagram,
you've got all
these different platforms.
And then if it's audio,
you've got SoundCloud and
podcasting platforms,
Stitcher, Google Voice,
iTunes, you create a podcast.
You just Google how
do I set up my podcast?
How do I distribute
my content?
But then you got to figure
out how do people discover it.
The where, right?
This is where you go into
ironically we're here again,
this is where we showed
you how to go
into the DM, right?
Or you gotta figure out how to
use the money and use Facebook
ads and target the people
that you're trying to reach.
Or grinding hustle, just
literally emailing 700 to 1,500
different blogs or media
sites and saying do you want to
distribute my content, right?
Emailing Entrepreneur magazine,
Inc. magazine,
Babysitting Weekly,
whatever it may be.
You gotta get distribution.
The way you do that is
either through time or money.
Money's easy,
Facebook ads, Google ads.
Time is hard but
if you have no money,
it's your only option.
So nobody's gonna cry for you
if you want people to know about
your stuff you need to find
other places that have eyeballs
or ears and get it out there.
So you need to ask to be a guest
on other peoples vlogs or
other people's blogs,
influencer marketing.
You know, these are the
things you need to figure out.
So, that's how you start.
I have a nice new
haircut and (laughs).
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)
- [Manny] Thank you.
- [Gary] You got it.
I appreciate it. Bye.
Just addicted to attention, man.
The attention.
Not like I need attention,
trading attention,
that's the game.
People don't get it.
Attention.
It's the only
thing that matters.
And then the next
thing that matters is
what do you say
with that attention.
That's it, one-two punch, baby.
("White Lines" by K.A.A.N.)